so you want to know about my first time
well why don't I just show you
there was a long dark and act
I was probably drinking more than I
should have was your health that was
reckless
I was ruthless I was sexy wait a minute
this isn't family friendly [ __ ] my first
time videos they're my favorite kind of
videos just add the title and my first
time and make a stupid [ __ ] face and
you got yourself millions of views boy
how about a how about an Alfie how about
that are you gonna click on this would
you click on this my first time my first
time ah nothing sexual nothing sexual
though guys it's family-friendly I love
this girl she's probably my favorite not
even trying to make your family friendly
my first time giving head hey guys is
Daisy here and welcome back to my
channel so today's video is gonna be a
story time
and his story time is gonna be all about
my first time giving head
I don't otherwise okay now before you
watch this video go ahead and subscribe
down below and go ahead and follow all
of my social media platforms I'm gonna
respectfully decline on that offer but I
do appreciate because it seemed like an
enticing enticing video further do you
want to go ahead and get what I am using
this bong Omar yeah what what just
happened anyway guys my arm let's get
[ __ ] hi everyone that's old school
hello YouTube has done it from my first
time video I haven't done one yet I was
on a school trip and I was playing spin
the bottle with the cool kids in
somebody's bedroom and the before landed
on me and a girl named it was me I don't
understand where you never called Daniel
what was wrong it was fate that dick
bottle landed on us
yeah even even companies adopted this
formula of my first time because of the
slightly sexual undertones their temper
did one we asked couples about their
first time a man I think the first time
was that my sisters yeah the guy at work
just kept on talking about how much he
and his wife liked it I didn't quite
know how to get into it like they're
talking about the family friendly [ __ ]
that's so hilarious that I think I might
just jump out the window and never this
has been great guys I appreciate you
alright I'm back first person uses you
subscribe to honey pity pie god these
first time tag videos I got dip terrible
I need to make one myself and show
everyone I can do it
where's the [ __ ] tag rules come on
where is there we go your first tweet
easy it was to Nelson Mandela I told him
I told him
yo dog let's make a YouTube channel I
think it's gonna be hella tight no reply
I don't understand what was wrong with
the tweet hey Nelson if you're watching
if you want to invest in underwater rats
he'll commit hook me up dog see still
alive it's not an alive Izzy my first
youtube video now a lot of people seem
to think it's this stupid minecraft
video minecraft it's not the first video
I did shocking prepare for this news
because I have a bunch of private Advani
channel that ain't nobody is ever gonna
see and if those videos come out in
public
I might just actually have to jump out
the window like I was saying call of
duty black ops hey guys it's me Peter
nope
hell no what is up you guys my name is
apparently saying that too loud is
annoying well I guess seven years later
I have still haven't learned
hey guys [ __ ] hell I was way cooler
back then kind of notice it when you
said it but I have to say it that is
just how it is
I remember this video very specifically
because it was the very first time
someone asked me to play more of amnesia
this is at the same time I transitioned
from call of duty to doing horror or
Let's Plays and so while I was recording
this someone wrote me being like hey
when's the next episode coming up and
I'm like yo Dawg it's coming hell yeah
it's gonna be you know but if it is so
then it's kind of weird because you
can't shoot down and a teammate's
claymores you can't shoot down their
choppers or anything why would you be
able to shoot down the [ __ ] dogs you
know hell yeah animals
I'm also wrecking this [ __ ] 37 - suck on
that noses toes [ __ ] first person I
subscribe to on YouTube jacksepticeye
raywilliamjohnson don't [ __ ] tell
anyone about that one okay it's the dark
times also come on everyone subscribed
raywilliamjohnson hey within a moment
first facebook profile pic I'm loving
this this is so easy I don't have to do
I just have to [ __ ] answer questions
I don't have to prepare anything the
best [ __ ] ever
ya know that's definitely a good picture
twenties 2007 10 years ago so you can't
even see me it's so backlit you can't
even [ __ ] sleep excellent choice of a
picture Felix I think you really need it
nailed it
can we try and let it up so we're like
we see how I actually look than that
okay well that's how I look like now
okay
a face only a mother can love excellent
do you still talk to your first love
then what happened we never talk anymore
I don't understand where did he go wrong
did you not like it what was your first
job I used to work at a tennis court in
the middle of nowhere and there was
really not much to do but I would take
care of the courts there was three of
them a lot of times it rained and I had
absolutely nothing to do and but sit
around and play guitar hero in the
Nintendo DS it was [ __ ] I'm pretty
good at it I'm pretty good I get our
hair on D s I think that's my main game
you know if anyone challenged me for a
duel in any game ever
I'd be like Guitar Hero D s [ __ ]
you earn attacks that show up as icons
on your touchscreen to launch these
attacks oh you look that's definitely
complete tap them the pyrotechnic attack
is very useful to put out the flames
your opponent blows them out with it
yeah you definitely needed a multiplayer
mode for this [ __ ] game what was your
first alcoholic drink back in the back
in the day we would have to you have to
be 21 to buy alcohol in Sweden unless
you're at a bar so what we would do
don't do this by the way but what we
would do was we would call this guy the
I don't know this random number he would
show up in the car dump a flock I don't
know what it's called in English a flock
of beer and it was this weird [ __ ]
like polish beer not cooled and I
remember just like we would we would
drink it like we were like we were a
[ __ ] condom icers I'm a beer like
oh wow so good good my god I love beer
what was your first car
and my mini that I haven't here in UK I
bought it I got a license when I was 21
is that still a meme I know it's a good
one yeah got a mini here really like it
I don't have it anymore I got a Volvo
now hell yeah
representing Sweden that's right got him
I'm just kidding I have six Lambos who
was your first teacher Maryanne hot babe
how are you doing baby hit me up know
why I'm hitting on my old teacher she's
probably like 80 70 years old
what was the first concert you ever went
to this is really what people give a
[ __ ] about there's nothing sexual what
was your first kiss so I was just
reminded of it I was at this party one
time and we were all sitting in a circle
and then one person was like hey we
should do spin a bottle and I'm kidding
I'm kidding I was I was really young I
was like 5 years old or some [ __ ] so I
don't written I don't think it counts
when you're that young yeah and only it
was with my first girlfriend Emmy I
remember we used to go and there was
like this little [ __ ] in school right I
don't know why I asked said it like you
know what I'm talking about there was
his little shed we would hide in there
and we would do what we in Sweden call
along with all that I which is basically
the the Lamborghini of kisses okay it's
basically you just do a kiss for a very
long time like at least three seconds
it's pretty it's pretty wild it's pretty
well I think it's time to wrap up this
video what do you think alright then
thank you for watching my first time and
I hope you learned a lot cuz I certainly
did also the first time I stuck a window